nos goûts alimentaires évoluent avec le
temps et ces changements là se reflète
dans nos champs après le quinoa voici
qu'une autre culture originaire de
l'amérique latine s'apprête à
s'implanter chez nous avec tous les
défis que cela représente
voici une plante inconnu au pays
cette plante exotique et pourtant une
culture millénaire et son nom nous est
de plus en plus familier le chien salvia
hispanica les peuples amérindiens en
particulier les aztèques
puis les mayas ont commencé la culture
du chien il y à plus de 4000 ans ces
civilisations sont nourrissait avant la
chasse ou la guerre
avec l'arrivée des espagnols la culture
du chien est tombé pour ne re surgir que
dans les années 90 dans des
exploitations commerciales du pérou du
mexique et de l'argentine
de nos jours on sait que les graines du
chien sont riches en assez d'oméga 3
d'où l'intérêt d'en faire la culture au
pays
ses graines sont en vogue et ce qui est
vendu en magasin ici est importé
mais ça pourrait changer dans ces
parcelles de culture à saint bruno de
montarville l'institut de recherche et
de développement en agroenvironnement
irda en est à sa troisième année d'essai
la culture est un peu petite échelle
mais les résultats sont valables on veut
savoir si le chien peut être cultivée au
pays
il a d'abord fallu aux chercheurs
trouver des semences adaptées à nos étés
car le chien fleuri tout près de
l'équateur où les périodes
d'ensoleillement ont 12 heures mais les
jours d'été ici sont plus longs jusqu'à
14 heures
on ne réussit à trouver en fait
chercheur à l'université du kent hockey
qui lui réussit à développer des lignées
qui fleurissent ou des photos période
longue
donc on ne travaille avec lui c'est lui
qui nous a fourni des lignes et deux au
départ puis après on a décidé de
travailler plus particulièrement avec
une de ces lignes est là le chien
appartient à la famille des plantes
aromatiques une porte des fleurs
semblable à celle de la menthe ou de la
souche
c'est une famille de plantes qui fait
souvent bain qui fondent et des fleurs
avec une hampe florale comme ça où on
retrouve plusieurs fleurs dans un camp
de chasse à voir fleurir pendant encore
quelques semaines donc celle qu'on voit
présentement vont tomber dans le dos qui
vont apparaître
effectivement après certain temps les
petites enveloppes et s'ils vont se dés
ses chips à l'intérieur de ces
enveloppes là qu'on va retrouver les
graines de chia le chien n'est pas une
légumineuse ni une graminée il est une
pseudo céréales comme le sarrasin ou le
quinoa ce qui fait de lui une excellente
culture de rotation
ça brise le sigle des maladies ça brise
le sec des insectes peuvent s'attaquer à
certaines cultures
donc c'est les avantages des rotations
général puisque c'est encore peut-être
plus important parce que c'est vraiment
une nouvelle famille de plantes
si les parcelles en culture biologique
de l'irda semble épargné par les
insectes ravageurs
elles font face à d'autres problèmes
d'abord les semences sont fragiles au
froid elles ont besoin d'être protégés
une quarantaine de jours mais surtout
c'est une plante qui n'est pas très
compétitive
les mauvaises herbes n'envahisse
on en voit ici quelques-unes des
graminées du pourpier qui pose pour la
chercheuse les mauvaises herbes
représente un des principaux défis dans
une approche préventive il faudrait
pratiquer un bon travail du sol avant
l'implantation des semis
ça serait con on travaille on épand ta
culture dans un sol où la banque de
mauvaises herbes et basse donc pas trop
de grains de mauvaises herbes qui vont
germer y venir compétionner avec le choc
et se retrouver avec des problèmes
particulièrement sur le rang le
mûrissement va se poursuivre comme la
culture est nouvelle la chercheuse n'est
sûr de rien mais elle croit que la
récolte aura lieu fin octobre dans deux
mois
[Applaudissements]
finalement la récolte a été retardé
les cultures ont souffert de l'été très
sec et de l' automne pluvieux
cette année on a eu des conditions de
sécheresse puis je dirais que la
maturité a été beaucoup plus lente
normalement les années passées on avait
récolté vers le 20 octobre
plus cette année vont se retrouvent le 9
novembre puis l'on va procéder à la
récolte
signe que le temps presse des ongles se
sont détachés des plans évident et si on
regarde si les hampes florales on en
voit qui ont perdu le des enveloppes
avec les graines à l'intérieur
s'ils gagnent eux sont tombés au sol
évidemment que si je prends une hampe
florale et je regarde
qu'est ce que je vois à l'intérieur je
vois que quand même des graines immature
brunâtre qui sont là le sol est détrempé
par les nombreux jours de pluie mais
aujourd'hui on estime qu'il pourra
supporter la batteuse on peut récolter
heureusement battre le chien dans de
petites parcelles de culture nécessaire
qu'une machine de format miniature
c'est le criblage qui permet de mesurer
la qualité et la quantité de bonnes
graines première étape
les graines sont nettoyées des impuretés
ensuite a lieu la séparation des graines
pour ne conserver que celles qui sont
mûrs josé boisclair remarque toutefois
une assez forte proportion d'une nature
c'est ce que ça prend un sol bien drainé
qu'il a avec ce qu'on a vu jusqu'à
maintenant le c'était la première année
qu'on cultive air en sol plus l'eau
jusqu'à maintenant votre ca performent
mieux dans un seul léger en culture
biologique
les rendements dans la vente de graines
de chia sont comparables ou revenus
obtenus par d'autres grains bio destinés
à l'alimentation humaine
les rendements à l'hectare qu'on a
observé salary entre un peu plus qu'une
tonne à un peu moins qu'une tonne et
demie dans quand 1,2 1,5 tonne à
l'hectare irna a déjà démontré que la
culture du chien est possible sous le
climat du québec et que les revenus à
l'hectare sont avantageux
reste à mettre au point quelques
techniques comme le désherbage et la
rigotte et il reste un autre défi pour
l'équipe de recherche faut poursuivre et
c'est d'aller de l'avant le port a
trouvé une solution à
l'approvisionnement en semences
cette plante du passé qui nous vient du
sud pourra alors se faire une place dans
les champs d'ici
[Musique]